comprenez vous l'appel au boycott contre
koh lanta ça tout le monde en a parlé
ça fait un tout les un tollé louis et
île vers 12 totalement parce qu'on a la
preuve ultime s'il leur fallait que
c'est scénarisé
pourquoi c'est parce que pendant
l'épisode pendant l'épisode au moment du
tournage noble et les gens de la
production qui sont là bas ils ont vu
deux choses les armes secrètes ça ne
servait à rien le bracelet noir on
l'utilisait pas et vincent surclassé
tout le monde
donc ils se sont dit on va cette
émission-là en profiter tant pis on
prend le risque on sort vincent et on
truc auquel se sont dit qu'ils allaient
surclassé tout le monde que ça n'avait
plus d'intérêt et ils ont préféré garder
thomas le paul négatif
c'est bien d'avoir annonce alors c'est
pas orientées comme ça sent mauvais
n'ont ils pas d'accord ses parents l'ont
été comme ça la dernière fois que j'ai
vu émerger comme ça c'est quoi ton
caddie de rendre la chèvre en fait c'est
peut-être mal monté mais c'est pas
orienter ses pas scénarisée du tocantins
faut arrêter avec cette légende de koh
lanta c'est scénarisé qu'est ce que tu
veux à leur mouvement
tu penses que c'est quoi non mais je
pense que ces braises est-ce que tu
comprends qu'il ait des gens qui
rappelait au noël ça c'est normal c'est
moi que c'est mal montée s'est orientée
à chaque fois qu'un est une candidate
qui est en galère
elle est là elle est comme par hasard
assise à côté du du bracelet magique
donc je pense qu'il faut travailler là
dessus ah ouais tu sais pas c'est maryse
et ouais non mais attends tu as toi
qu'est-ce que j'en veux dire faire koh
lanta laisse moi tranquille
ouais qu'est ce que tu veux dire voilà
je viens de dire je vais gilles verdez
qu'est ce qu'il vient de dire s'il te
plaît il vient de dire que c'était pas
scénarisée et il a menti et j'attends de
voir ce qu'ils vont lire tous les deux
parce que ça connaît mal écrit ce
week-end
c'est ok j'attends avec impatience la
sonapar oui un bottom gilou s'adonne
alors à dix alors moi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec jill
balsamique routière ça côté de l'écran
mais passer entièrement scénarisée et on
a la preuve
parce qu'en fait si vous voulez la
production formosa marie curie en jeu du
jeune curé mercure et de fait aso sont
comme ça c'est qu'on oublie clairement
la production clairement la production
tient les ficelles le seul ils peuvent
vraiment n'a influencé surtout le cours
du jeu d'accord en créant des nouvelles
règles on l'a vu il ya trois semaines
d'un cran de nouvelles règles et les
écoliers sont pas cachés sata dégoûté ça
non mais parce que du coup finalement le
candidat
les candidats quand ils vont finalement
vous on n'a aucune chance à des
virements no more heroes faire koh lanta
vietnam et la production en fait par
exemple les cogner comme dirait agiles
les colis ne sont pas cachés avant que
je commence
ils sont cachés au cours du jeu et cee
en fait c'est leur ami rahman qui le
glisse enfin pendant le cours du jeu
quand ils veulent que le ca ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai çà mau mau mau mau
bonbons regarde-moi au début on regarde
maintenant savoir hier que ma voix à
momo elle perd son lourd jafar est ce
que c'est vrai ce que tu dis ça comme ça
le les bracelets sont ils sont ils sont
glissées çà çà çà çà çà çà c'est là
aussi mais pas au début
au début du jeu mais de là à dire que
koh lanta c'est scénarisé je suis contre
ces scénarii âmes est alors question
c'est à dire qu'il choisisse le moment
où ils veulent le donner à quelqu'un
oui mais il ne donne pas directement
merci lequel on rien qu'en gros mais je
l'aï fait pendant que le candidat il
cherche le candidat il cherche faut
savoir que caméraman vivent avec nous ça
ils ont ils ont ils sont près du
campement et c'est à dire en fait les
candidats ils cherchent le collier il
l'introduit dans la zone de recherche
douala et donc forcément vous allez
trouver des cibles à la vrt denis
brogniart ils m'ont dit le début quand
il dit par exemple au début de cette
aide cette aventure là il dit il ya les
armes secrètes chercher des armes
secrètes à m'énerver mais aucune arme
secrète cachée sur l'île
aucune part peut-être quelques judma
crise en introduisant en cours de jeu et
puis alors j'ai une
une question qui chamboule mais vraiment
qu'une chamboule c est ce qu il ya le
livre de la prod ce que j'entends le
livre de la prod ses esquives ya écrit
les règles ça veut dire est ce que le
collier noir qu'elle est enfin le
brassard noir qu'elle éliminait collier
d'immunité est ce que c'est écrit à
l'avancé des billets avec moi la réponse
est oui alors alors vous avez beaucoup
parlé ce soir gilles verdez voit des
complots partout et servez-les island
mais il aimerait aller travailler chez
julien d'accord mais la coop candide
mais n'ont même pas du tout d'abord
s'ils pensaient que la prod et 10
annonce vincent c'est un excellent
candidat
il fait le show et oui tout le monde va
l'adorer qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour
que ça fonctionne bien sûr à l'éliminer
by trouve personne oui mais non on va
jouer juste cynique mais il est juste
extraordinaire mais je suis super déçue
de sa de son élimination et pour autant
et en plus ils plantent pas avant les
armes secrètes
parce que vous savez il ya des messages
dessus et avec la pluie ça c'est face à
cette voix là probablement simplement la
réponse avec elisha moi je pense que la
prod s'est fait avoir dans sa
supercherie
moi je pense que cette personne elle est
juste victime du jeu on a les personnes
qui sont quand même plus apte que nous à
savoir ce qui se passe dans la prod si
on nous dit que les colliers sont mis
devant la personne qui est en train de
chercher comme ça s'il redonner la
reynard de la production chez vous le
donnez moi je suis entièrement d'accord
qu'il y avait la pêche et que tu vois tu
veux quelque chose
les cieux à lacets de la polémique on a
contacté la production pour avoir sa
version des faits concernant une
éventuelle triche dans l'émission les
internautes ont reproché de la musique
derrière le choix de l'uci d'avoir
utilisé son arme secrète pour aider
maxime qui n'en avait pas moins pas
besoin mais selon la production
l'uci qui est très proche de maxime
s'est servi du bracelet noir qui permet
de voler un collier d'immunité à
quelqu'un d'autre parce qu'elle était
très proche d'elle dans l'émission et
qu'elle craignait pour elle tout
simplement
ensuite concernant la découverte par
l'uci de ce fameux bracelet noir tu
comprends ce que tu donnes l'internaute
accusé la prod
d'abord amis cette arme secrète à ce
moment là pour que lucide le trouve et
élimine vincent les petits secrets de
production
quelle grandeur les armes secrètes sont
placés avant le début du jeu sur l'île
filmée et faire des plans de coupe pour
tout expliquer aux télés smith a en fait
le je pense que le vin sans senna ça
dommage collatéral voilà ils ont
introduit fallait qu'ils arrêtent et
d'introduire des choses
alors oui en fait j'avais combien de
pourcentage de chances que le un
candidat trouve le collier et qui
trouvent et un autre candidat trouve le
collier noir
ils ont fait exprès que les deux
candidats le trouve au même moment pour
sortir et ça c'est beau